- We did it! This city means the world to me. Tampa forever!
All right, only 30 more teams to go. Gronk, we're out.
- But Gronk just bought a house.
- Just buy another one—
- [Jared Goff:] Look at this guy. A Super Bowl-winning quarterback.
Me? I lost a Super Bowl, and two years later, they shipped me off to Detroit with this guy—
- WOO! WELCOME TO THE LION CAGE! HAVE DINNER OR BECOME DINNER!
- [Goff:] They traded Stafford to L.A.—
- OH GOD, THE SUN.
- [Goff:] For me, a third and two firsts.
- Oh! Gotta tip. Here’s our 2024 first-round pick.
- [Goff:] Suddenly, the price for a QB increased even more,
which gave one man an idea...
- TAYSOM…we’re gonna drive up the price of quarterback stock.
Hello, media, can I interest you in Taysom Hill?
He’s Mormon but also old.
- [Media on phone:] Well, gosh, I don’t know—
- TAYSOM COULD PUNT AND RETURN THE SAME KICK.
- Well, all right! Taysom to the moon, baby! Lock me in!
- I got you, no cap.
- [Goff:] Confusing? Here’s Adam Lefkoe in a bathtub to explain.
- The Saints are $100 million over the salary cap already, and
this year, the cap is actually going to get LOWER for the first time in a decade.
So the Saints need to increase Taysom’s trade value.
You guys are going to make me look good, right?
- So Taysom is now worth $40 million a year? Hmmm.
- So, is the exit interview over?
- THEY ARE MAKING MORE MONEY THAN ME.
WE NEED TO IMPOSE RESTRICTIONS.
- Maybe Taysom is good?
- NO, EVERYTHING IS ABOUT MON—
- Great season, Team State Farm!
[car horn, honking]
Yeah, honk for State Farm!
- MONEY, EVERYTHING.
- [Goff:] So with Taysom rising, the price on more experienced QBs went through the roof.
- Dang it, Dakky. I gotta sell my Jumbotron to pay ya!
- This is why you should have extended me earlier, Jerral.
- Used car! Selling a lightly used car, man. I mean, this baby still drives, man.
- Look, the internet says now I’m worth half a Darnoldcoin.
- TAYSOM, WATCH ME DANCE.
- [Taysom Hill:] Uh, Coach. You should trade me—
- HOLD THE LINE.
- Sorry, Deshaun. If Taysom Hill is now worth 10 firsts,
then no one on planet Earth can afford you.
- I appreciate your time.
- [Goff:] And just like that, the QB market crashed overnight,
which produced…pure chaos.
- NO TEAM IS BETTER THAN SOME TEAMS!
- Protect me, uh...uh…Hurts...or Wentz, or Wentz...uh, um…or Hurts. Or Wentz.
- It’s gonna be good to get back—
Man, I hate this f--king sport.
- I need to figure out a way to cover this up.
- Did somebody say "cover-up"?
- [Roger Goodell:] URBAN MEYER!
- Introducing: young kids you don’t need to pay.
- WOAH, WHAT?!
- Thank you all so much for watching this season.
It’s a real shame it has to end.
You know what...I'm not leaving.
I’m not f--king leaving. THE SHOW GOES ON!
WOOO!
- Clammy no. The season actually is over—
- THEY CAN NEVER SILENCE ME AS LONG AS YOU ALL
BUY DELAWARE CLAMS SHIRTS IN THE
BLEACHER REPORT STORE.
- Alright, the clam is belligerent. Send in Teamy.
- SHIRTS SHOULD BE ABOUT TEAMY.
- COME AT ME, YOU F--KING PIECE OF S--T.